نفر جب ان انش او لا تعطي اي بوصه القتال
من اجل امريكا التي احب كتاب جديد اصدره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي السابق مايك
بومبيا اسرار كثيره وفي اكثر من ملف تحدث
بومبيو في الكتاب عن ايران طبعا في 2018
سرق الارشيف النووي الايرانيين من قلب
طيران واحده من اهم العمليات السريه خلال
الفتره الاخيره وكان لواشنطن دورا في ذلك
اسرائيل طلبت مساعدته عبر مدير
الموسى يواجهون بعض الصعوبات في اخراج
بعضا من الملفات هل يمكن مساعدتنا هكذا
اقربكم في الكتاب وبالفعل نجح حكيم مساعده
اسرائيل
وليس ممله مثل كتب الحملات الانتخابيه
وهكذا يصف الكاتب الامريكي الفائز بجائزه
سمسم الكتاب الجديد
والاص كثيره وهذا سر اخر كشف عنه الكتاب
مقتل القاسم سليماني لا فرق بين ايران
وتنظيمات ارهابيه مثل القاعده التي يقع
معقلها الرئيسيه في طيران وليس افغانستان
هكذا يا رب في ايران ومن اجل ذلك تحركت
واشنطن للتخطيط لقتل سليماني بمبي يشارك
في اجتماع عقده ترامب في ديسمبر 2019 في
ماروكو بمشاركه وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان
واوضح خلال الاجتماع خطط سليماني لقتل
المزيد من الامريكيين ما جعله هدفا عسكريا
مشروعا بحسب طنطا الاداره الامريكيه كانت
تعلم طبعا ان عمليه سليمان لو تمت بنجاح
فسياتي قائد الاخر لكن كان لبومبي رئيا
مختلف سياتي جنرال اخر نعم لكن لا احد
سيكون لديه المزيج من السلطه والعقول
والوحشيه محاوله استبداله ستش ومحاوله
تغيير لوحه اصليه باخرى مقلده
ملفنا مثير اخر كشف عنه كمفيه وهذه المره
يخص الهند وباكستان مكالمه عبر الهاتف منع
حرب النوويه بين البلدين في 2019 النزاع
بين الطرفين كان على اشده في فبراير تفجرت
الاوضاع اكثر جاء شهر مارس كان موعد قمه
في هنوين بين ترامب وزعيم كوريا الشماليه
في نهايه احد ايام القمه للنوم لكنه
مكالمه في الليل ابدا والم مسؤول هنديا
كفي كبير الباكستانيون يعدون اسلحتهم
النوويه لتنفيذ ضربه وهذا هو مضمون
المكالمه ترى النوم من اعين بامبيو اعطى
او امره للديبلوماسيين الامريكيين الذين
اقنعوا الهند وباكستان بان لا يستخدم احد
منهما الاسلحه النوويه القصص في كتاب
بامبي وكثيره ومنها ما يخص الرئيس الفرنسي
مكرونه ايضا
[موسيقى]